السابق يخرج الان من قاعه المحاكمه في
نيويورك على ان يتوجه ويعود الى فلوريدا
حيث سنستمع الى كلمه له لاحقا هذه الليله
يمكن ان نعيد هذه الصور مره اخرى اذا
نعيدها عليكم مره اخرى الرئيس ترامب يبدو
رئيس السابق يبدو خارجا من قاعه المحكمه
ومن خلفه بعض ممن كانوا في داخلها بعد ما
نفى لائحه الاتهام التي وجهت اليها اذا
مشهد تاريخي طاهر نشاهد ترامب يخرج من
قاعه المحكمه بعد يوم طويل وجهت خلاله من
قبل محاكمات من هاتن لائحه الاتهامات
لائحه الاتهامات التي رفضها بكل تفاصيلها
طبعا لائحه الاتهام
تتضمن تقديم روشه لشراء سكوت امراه وايضا
تزوير سجلاته التجاريه قبل انتخابات عام
لا اصدق بان هذا يحصل في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يبدو الامر سرياليا للغايه يا
للهول سيتم توقيف لا اصدق ان هذا يحدث في
امريكا انا ذاهب الى المحكمه كان كتب ذلك
على تشوث سوشل خرج الان من المحكمه اذا
هذه الصوره من الجانب الذي هو في خارج
المحكمه في الهواء الطلق الان قبل ان
يستقل موكبه مجددا الى المطار ليعود الى
فلوريدا طبعا
يتواجد مقره كان هناك تصريح اضافي لترامب
في وصف ما يحصل قال هذه الاتهامات مثيره
للشفقه وانها اضطهاد سياسي نشاهد ترامب
بسيارته يستقل سيارته في هذا اليوم
التاريخي اذا ترامب يغادر مبنى محكمه من
هاتن بعد توجيه الاتهامات له اول رئيس
امريكي في المنصب او سابق توجه له اتهامات
جنائيه
عاما وجهت له هيئه المحلفين الاتهامات في
قضيه تتعلق اذا بدفع اموال لشراء صمت نجمه
الافلام الاباحيه
وقد افرج عن الرئيس الامريكي السابق
بكفاله لكي يتم اطلاق سراحه
واخلاء سبيله ولكي يذهب الى فلوريدا قبل
ان تبدا المحاكمه لاحقا وهذا كما قلنا قد
يطول بشكل كبير ربما نتحدث عن اشهر طويله
او حتى عن عام يعني اشهر عشيه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله التي قد يكون مرشحا لها
اذا موكب ترامب يغادر محكمه من هاتن بعد
اخلاء سبيله